[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator TV
and broadcast on Thursday the 7th of
December I'm John Connelly The
Spectators news editor and your host
this week coming up on the show the Tory
party is in a state about Rwanda after
immigration Minister Robert gri resigned
over the issue this week One Wing of the
party the government's new bill and
agreement with Rwanda goes too far
others believe it does not go far enough
Katy balls and Peter Walsh will join me
on the show Katie will stay with us to
talk about her cover piece does starma
stack up looking at what the labor
leader would do wi power she'll be
joined by Sally
Morgan own Matthews writes in this
week's magazine that Ukraine and Russia
will eventually be pushed to the
negotiating table he'll discuss with
Dimitri
alperovich the Royal racist Saga is
still raging the palace released a show
of unity photo this week Keen to show
that everything is fine but is it I'll
speak to Angela Levan and lastly Sam
Leaf will tell us about his books of the
year before we get going if you enjoy
spectator TV do subscribe to our YouTube
channel just click the Subscribe button
at the bottom of this video and tap the
Bell icon so you never miss an
episode first up immigration Minister
Robert jri resigned last night over the
government's Rwanda Bill to tell us
what's going on Katy balls joins me now
alongside Peter Walsh from Oxford
University's migration
Observatory ktie and Peter thank you for
joining us on spectator TV um Katie
start us off so Robert grick resigned
last night over the government's Rwanda
bill um can you sort of bring people up
to speed about what happened and and
what's happened since his resignation
yes there are a few components in a way
the big news of yesterday should have
been the fact that government was
unveiling its official Plan B on rander
so the fact that they I think when
you're talking to Tor MPS there was this
skimmed version which didn't go near
international law there was the full fat
version that sella Braven was talking
about and there was a semi skimmed
version I think they've gone some of
between semi skimmed and full fat in the
sense that on the bill there is a note
at the very front of it by the Home
Secretary effectively saying that he
cannot guarantee that this is in line
with the
ECR but it does not have the not
withstanding Clauses that Su bravman was
calling for and it therefore is uh you
know in terms of disapply things it
disapply parts of the human rights act
but it does not completely ignore these
things and therefore you quite quickly
had uh sella bravman for example and her
supporters suggesting it doesn't look
like enough but there are legal teams
looking at it but the biggest problem
for Rishi cak was he addressed the 1922
Committee of Tory MPS to say here's my
plan it's unite or die get behind this
take the fight to labor and then the Q&A
was broadly supportive a few more
skeptical questions but the one that
really set the cat amongst the pigeons
was from Mark frir who said has Robert
jenrich resigned now in recent weeks
very recent weeks since had a bra was
sacked Robert jenrick has become almost
the unlikely figurehead for the right
within government um he's a close Ally
of richy sunak or at least he used to be
and he has been speaking out
suggesting effectively that the
government should listen to him sooner
and while being imposed so I don't think
it's completely surprising that he has
stepped down over this but the problem
for Richi sunak is after that question
about an hour or so later it was
eventually confirmed that Robert jenrick
has quit government and he's put out a
statement saying he ultimately has too
many disagreements with number 10's
approach and immigration and migration
now in terms of what that means to Rishi
it's one resignation but it's a close
Ally but it's sending a signal I think
to the right of the party that your
immigration Minister can't back it
should they that said it's worth
pointing out that bill cash was broadly
supportive in that meeting and also Lord
sumption has been very supportive saying
that he thinks the legislation could
actually work but definitely through a
very big spanner in the works of the
Prime Minister Peter what did you make
of the legislation obviously this has
been brought in because the Supreme cour
in November said the Randa scheme was
unlawful I mean do you think it solves
that
problem um it goes quite some way
towards solving that problem it will
make it considerably easier to relocate
people to Rwanda I mean the thing that's
so striking about it is just how
comprehensive and tightly worded it is
in instructing decision makers and in
particular we think of the courts in
disregarding all aspects of UK law
that's the human rights act all
references to non
reement um all of the basis of UK law
upon which the Supreme Court said Rwanda
is not a safe country the bill proposes
to change the law so that the Supreme
Court if it were to revisit it they
would have no choice but to say okay yes
we follow the injunction of this bill so
it makes it considerably easier to send
people to Rwanda but what I expect will
happen is most entrance to the UK they
will claim Asylum they will appeal
against their removal um that legal
challenge will be refused but then they
will have the opportunity to challenge
their removal which may already have
taken place to the Strasburg court and
that will allow the Strasburg Court to
make a ruling on the overall legality of
the policy there's no longer the
opportunity for people to resist their
removal on the basis of Rwanda generally
not being safe they can still say it's
not safe for me that might be on the
basis say of them having criticized the
kagami regime in the past things of that
nature but the bar is so high that those
appeals are likely to fail but that then
takes them to the European Court of
Human Rights and they may rule quite
differently and they will be able to
rule on the overall legality of the
policy so it really takes us back to
this question of our relationship with
the Council of Europe and whether we
would withdraw from the European Court
of Human Rights yeah Casey there's some
irony there because it feels like well
when swell brovman did her speech
yesterday she kind of said well we don't
I know even though I want to leave the
European Court of Human Rights it's not
something we need right now I mean do
you think there's going to be a movement
back towards that in the in the Tory
party now yes I think that initially
when it came to the supreme court
judgment there was a feeling it could
move straight to we need to leave the
echr but quite notably when uh the
Supreme Court were going through their
judgment they said this isn't actually
just about the ECR they made a point of
saying that saying it's not a silver
bullet but it feels like so we're on
that path I think it's just worth
flagging that when it comes to how MPS
are going to react to this policy now
you have the Star Chamber you have the
one nation lawyers all looking at
it but the question for those on the
right of the party is what richy told
MPS and what he said in his letter to
Robert jri accepting his resignation is
the re wanding government would not
support Su Bran's plan which is if you
go one inch further as a prime minister
put it and you uh you have these
notwithstanding Clauses you're so firmly
he argued um breaching international law
that the Rwanda scheme would go now that
means that s bravman has supporters
Robert jenrich then need to say well
what do they think the plan is because
AR they saying and I think s braan in
her interview in the today program
appeared to hint a little bit so she
maybe she didn't trust richy cak on this
maybe she thought Rich was not being
honest in terms of um the realities of
the Ron government they've also put out
similar statements are they saying they
think that effectively the UK government
could say we're doing this the Randa
government will fall into line or are
they saying they might not but this bill
is not going to work anyway so there's
no point wasting our time on it and
therefore you need a bit more clarity on
that side I think it complicates what
the response is in terms of the ECR I
think the beginning of the year Richie
St has put himself on a path to
potentially leaving the echr by making
stop the boats his almost Flagship
policy and that is a policy which relies
not just on MPS who are in a in some
ways predictable in some ways
unpredictable you can be both at the
same time sometimes you know not just
MPS and peers but also the courts it was
always a root that if things did not go
his way he could be left before an
election with so few things to say on
the topic that he feels as though he
needs to put a pledge to leave the ECR
in the manifesto Now Rich has never said
he's against it what he said is he's yet
to be convinced it is necessary so I
think to the what we've just been
hearing if you find a situation where I
think there still a question mark
whether this bill would even become law
because of the Tory tribes but say it
were to Len it gets held up by
Strasburg at that point I think the next
step would be to say we are going to put
in the Manifest believeing e Asia Peter
I mean in that case you know there was a
lot of steps between now and then but
can you can you ever sort of envisage a
situation or a scenario where migrants
are sent to Rwanda can you actually see
that
happening um yes I can I mean the bill
certainly takes steps to make that much
easier I suppose in the short term the
biggest question is will it pass
Parliament you know there are a number
of people who foresee um the Lords um
potentially being quite a large obstacle
especially in the light of the bill
really essentially saying yes we are
committed to a path um on which we will
violate um our obligations under under
international law one suspects the Lords
may take issue with that so that's the
really big question I think in the short
term if it were to pass Parliament and
become law it does appear to make
flights to Rwanda much more viable at
least in the short term um illegal
migration act in conert with this makes
that possible of course then further
down the line much will depend um on the
Judgment of the ECR I think it's very
interesting hearing that just in the
sense that Tori andp are yet to make up
their minds completely but I think the
fact you hear that and then you also see
what lord supon said saying that he
thought that this would actually allow
for flights to take off but it did risk
breing international law it feels very
out of lock step of what Su bravman is
saying now she was accused this morning
of being on leadership Maneuvers but it
does mean as in you can see the mood
music from some the Tor wanting to say
it's not enough there's lots of Tory MPS
right now saying you know it's back to
the brexit years if the legislation
actually suggests that it can do what it
it does and you have more figures coming
out to say that I think it would start
to look as though almost an anti-ac
sentiment to oppose it if you have
enough legal minds and so forth saying
this actually gives you quite a good
chance particularly when you combine it
with what the Rwandan government is
saying um Casey we should say as well so
the the bill is being voted on in the
Commons on Tuesday is that right the day
of the spectator editor of the Christmas
R well there we go very good what could
go
wrong um Richi sunak made not made that
a confidence vote do you think that's
significant or do you think he's just
playing it cautious at this stage I
think in a way to make it a confidence
vote would be the thing that's
significant um he could choose to
completely face in his MPS but if Rich
said this morning this is a confidence
issue I think we now will be talking
which is are we going to have a December
election it would be upping the stakes
in such a way yeah but realistically it
might not be a confidence vote but if
rishy sunet cannot get this through in
the sense that if Le Tory Rebels whether
it's on the one nation Wing or the right
and we're yet to hear but the one nation
Wing is worth pointing out they're
finding this pretty hardcore so you have
M who's on the right saying it doesn't
go far enough on the other side saying
this goes way too far so if you have
enough Rebels that then team up with
labor labor saying they will oppose it
rich is running out of road to deliver
on a key pledge and I think his
authority would be very shot ktie you're
going to stay with us now to discuss
your cover cover piece with baroness
Morgan former Aid Tony Blair
now ktie you write in the cover piece
this week well you ask does starma stack
up which I think points to the fact that
not many of us know that feel like we
don't know starma very well or what he's
going to be like when he comes into
power or if he comes into Power next
year I should say um he's ruffled Sun
feathers this week he's prais Margaret
Thatcher you mentioned that at the
beginning of your piece can you tell us
a bit about what the thinking is there
what's he trying to get across yes so I
think over the weekend there was much
excitement because K St praised Margaret
Thatcher didn't specifically praise her
policies but said she she affected
meaningful change just perhaps change
that the labor party does not like um
and brought her up in relation to Tony
Blair and Clement Atley as an example of
three prime ministers who actually had a
vision and a plan clearly trying to
associate himself with them but I think
specifically knew fully well what he was
doing by throwing Margaret Thatcher in
there and as you would expect quite
quickly left of the party he started to
say this you know this is awful she's
not anything good you even had a few
Blair rights joining in saying you know
actually kid that's a bit
much but it's something we've seen K St
do in the past which is often you know
when I think they want to grab some news
in a weekend they write a slightly right
leaning uh oped for the Sunday Telegraph
and then everyone says wow k st's p you
know wow K st's you know parked his tank
on you know Tory Lawns look at him and
but I think the point I'm make in the
piece is I think it does just add to the
sense we're in a weird situation right
now where increasingly I think lots of
people just decided there is going to be
a labor government for good reason if
you look at the polls recent local
election results and so forth um you
know media business when you speak to
people is almost when you did it just
then we were introducing the segment you
know when he is prime minister obviously
it hasn't happened yet and in labor they
say don't you know don't be complacent
but yet for this almost feeling of near
certainty that he is going to be the
next prime minister I think you stop
people and said what is he going to do
as prime minister they don't really know
and you have a kir who praised thater
but you also have the k who when he was
going for the leadership called Jeremy
Corbin his friend um you have the kiss
Arma who talked about you know
preserving free movement when he was
running for the labor leadership but he
recently called the net migration figure
shockingly high and all those things his
team can argue well he had to do that to
get to where he is but I think there's
been a few too many things like that
where there is just a bit of doubt about
what he would really do and whether you
can take him as word Sally I mean what
do you think about that strategy do you
think after certain point he's going to
have to make clear what he actually
stands for or am I being a bit unfair
there I mean I think he's he's sort of
doing what quite often happens with
other leaders I think I I think from
distant memory I think Tony Blair said
he was socialist when he stood to be
labor leader so these things are not
unknown um and I think I think
essentially what K's done is he's taken
the party on a journey he's he's he's
effectively sorted the party out he's
now trying to turn himself properly to
the country I if I'm with him I wouldn't
say a great deal actually before the
election I think he's got to be clear
this is the type of leader and prime
minister I would be and I think look I
think his position difficult though it's
been on Israel Gaza has been um sort of
symptomatic of that in a sense he said
this is what you will get if I am prime
minister not I'm spending all my time
looking over the shoulder my shoulder to
manage my party which bluntly is what's
happening at the moment in the Tories um
because in the end the key thing that
people need to think I think is this is
going to be a proper prime minister who
is going to think about the country as a
whole not be too pragi about his party
and I so I think I think the way he's
doing it is right do I think he'll have
to give a bit more of an indication of
how that happens yes I do and so you
know if I were him and his team now I
would be pretty focused on saying we
can't do everything it's we are going to
inherit an absolute nightmare we
therefore will have to set out extremely
clear priorities um and not pretend we
can sort everything out and I think I
think if you look at I think W treatings
um visit to Australia is interesting
from that point of view I think he's
been pretty clear there's going to be a
lot of Reform I think there are some
areas that are easier for labor to
reform than conservatives and vice versa
by the way I've always thought the
conservatives can sort of Reform defense
and labor can reform the Health Service
more easily um so I think K's got to set
out what his absolute priorities are but
I don't think he should give too much
detail because that will then
preoccupy um it'll preoccupy the it'll
pry people like you Katie too because in
a sense it gives you stuff to get stuck
into in a way that probably is not
hugely helpful I mean s so you mentioned
about when labor come into power here I
think sort of traditionally people would
think when labor come in they raise
taxes they raise spending um the tax
burd's in a pretty high position right
now there's not loads of room in the
economy how do you think they'll sort of
manage that I mean I think what they've
got to do personally is and I it's what
I say to people you're going to have to
be really clear how difficult it's going
to be and and that and you're going to
have to find things that mightn't be
hugely popular but are also very cheap
um so you know if you take housing
there'll be quite a lot of change needs
to happen in regulation planning which
actually isn't about the government
spending money but it is about taking
some hard decisions and changing you
know so I think I think you've got to
look for things that are switching
priorities I think quite often quite
small policies and decisions are really
important because they paint a picture
and so I would be looking for what can
we do what what are we going to do in
the first in our first 100 days what's
our first King speech going to be
because that's got to have some symbolic
things in it that that Show a show a
direction of travel for government but
they have also got to say to people you
have got to give us two terms actually
and the other thing I would do is I
would seek out I would seek out people
across the parties who in a sense are
pro-reform want Britain to move forward
and I would I would actively seek to to
make sure that you are yeah you're
creating a you know a biger tent in
terms of saying we we want to work with
you if you're on if you're willing to
work we work with us and we'll move
things forward um because I think then
if people won't cooperate in that sort
of approach they can't really complain I
mean ktie you're right in your piece
about Labor's growth plan it seems like
everyone now seems committed that
Britain needs to grow more I mean you
mentioned the some issues there as well
with that can you tell us a little bit
about it yes I think one of the problems
lab have had and I quote uh you know
people who work for kid St in the peace
uh effectively saying you know they feel
as though they don't actually have much
of an incentive for put foring that many
policies because when they do I the
Tores Nick the policy or they say it's
rubbish for months on end um so
therefore wouldn't you just hold it to
near the election and you currently have
you know this bulletproof Squad um led
by Jonathan Ashworth that's going for
every policy to try and make sure if
it's going the manifesto the Tories
can't tear it apart but you look at
their growth plan as you say I think
it's pretty uncontroversial to say you
want growth K starma can sound a bit
like Liz trust when he says he's going
for growth um but it seems to form
largely of two parts so one is planning
reform and particularly uh there's
infrastructure planning reform there's
obviously also planning reform in terms
of more homes but quite a lot that's
social housing um it can still add to
growth in some ways then you also have
the working deal so new working deal for
uh people which it's seen as a progra
measure but of course that progra
measure um does also mean you know more
complications for employers um you know
one of the measures in it which I think
is quite interesting and probably would
fill my boss with horror is this right
to disconnect um whereby uh you look at
the uh what the France did in 2017 and
this idea that you know there' obviously
be some caveats but bosses couldn't
bother staff on weekends they're
technically out of hours with messages
that could be banned no um that will
need to go to consultation parts of this
with business so I don't think it will
necessarily be it is but I think that uh
you know is something where yes is doing
this amazing business charm offensive
and Rachel re was having lots of smoked
salmon and scrambled eggs but there are
concerns about you know what is going to
happen with those parts of it but then I
think the really controversial thing is
the Green Spending so that's the 28
billion now Rachel Rees has already
delayed what is a large part of the
labor industrial strategy of you know
Green borrowing green subsidies um
saying that they wouldn't be able to do
in their first year they plan to by you
know mid that Parliament when it comes
to reaching the 28 billion figure now
you have k St when he talks about we're
not going to spend you know turn the
spending Taps on people say well are you
definitely going to do your green growth
plan because things have changed since
you announced it interest rates
borrowing costs much higher this is if
it meets our fiscal rules now if you
look at what's expected of growth in
debt it looks as though that be maybe
2028 that they could bring that in but
it depends on if you things going right
and also them not spending money
elsewhere of course when you when you
work all together so you have almost a
large part of the growth strategy that
you can't have until you have growth so
it's a little bit chicken and egg I
think in that sense um and there is some
skepticism of whether it will happen so
there are parts to it I think the
planning reforms something where the
Tories have clearly failed but karma
would need a sizable majority because
planning is not something which you know
perhaps the Tories are a little bit more
NIMBY in terms of some of their seats um
but you know it's not just one party
where MPS be worried about issues with
their
constituents um Sally moving on to a
slightly different issue I mean it it's
been a long time now since labor have
been in power I mean do you think
they've got the institutional memory
there do you you know someone who's
worked in government do you think
they're going to find it difficult when
they first walk if they first walk
through Downing Street I mean I I think
actually strangely enough there's there
are probably more people around not who
are going to be in government but more
people still around the system in the
broader family if you want to v a word
than there were in 97 um I mean there
was nobody really um
and I think they are putting I think
they're putting some serious thinking
into to how do we actually behave as a
government and how do we run things
properly uh and I think look I think sug
gray will be incredibly helpful from
that point of view because having
somebody who really does understand
White Hall and and you know what the
relationship should be with a minister
and a and a senior civil to get the best
out of both I think is really helpful so
I am actually I know it's very popular
to say oh you know it's such a long time
and it is a long time but I I'm I'm I
would be a lot less I I think actually
there'll also be a feeling if labor wins
and it's exactly this is not a party
political point the Civil Service the
good civil servants love the stimulus
and the excitement of a new team who've
got a new set of ideas and priorities
because it you know it's it's it's it's
it's interesting and it's stimulating
and it's intellectually challenging so
they've got to make sure that they get
the best out of people um but I think
there's enough people around to to to
help talk them through that brilliant
Katy Sally thank you very
much oh matth writes in this week's
magazine about how Ukraine and Russia
will eventually need to negotiate for
peace to explain his argument Owen joins
me now alongside Dimitri alperovich
chairman of the Silverado policy
accelerator Owen and Demitri thank you
for joining us on spectator TV um Owen
you WR in the magazine this week that
the war in Ukraine can now only end with
a peace deal um when did you think it
became sort of clear that that Ukraine
couldn't win this war outright and that
and that a compromise would have to be
reached with with
Russia
uh well um this was clear immediately
from the beginning that uh Ukraine was
more or less I mean it's the full defeat
of Russia and the removal of the Putin
regime um would be a nice goal but
actually you know it's the nuclear
biggest nuclear armed power in the world
um if we're talking about defeating
Russia in the sense of actually you know
defeating it comprehensively as you know
Germany and Japan were defeated in 1945
that was never really going to happen
um the the thing that's been unclear up
to this point is how far the the
ukrainians would be able to get in terms
of their counter offensive in terms of
pushing uh Putin's troops out of the
territory they occupied since um
February of last year and um that's I
think what's changed over the last month
particularly with the Ukrainian um chief
of general staff um Val is alusion
announcing in The Economist last month
that there was not going to be magical
breakthrough um and I think
the there are um officially um several
of the senior people that I spoke to
zinsky people that I spoke to in Kiev
over the last couple of weeks uh believe
still that they'll be able to do for
better in a spring offensive but um
frankly I'm not sure how that's going to
happen because they don't have air
superiority even if they do get f-16s
they're not really really going to
achieve the same the kind of
overwhelming air super superiority that
they need for a massive breakthrough and
they're basically going to be in the
same situation as they are now which is
fighting through a very deep and uh
comprehensively defended uh barrier of
um trenches and minefields and so on so
the idea that Ukraine is actually going
to you know realistically throw Putin
out of its territory en
is now I think pretty much off the cards
Demetri do you think now is a good time
to cut a
deal no I I do agree with uh Owen though
that at some point there will be
negotiations almost every War uh in
history uh or certainly modern history
has ended in negotiations and not
unconditional surrenders and no one
thinks that Russia will will take an
unconditional surrender or you could
force them to the problem however is
that this war has never really been
about about territory for for either
side um in the case of Vladimir Putin
territory is not really what he's
primarily focused on he doesn't really
care that much if he takes the town of
bmud as he did this year or if he takes
the village or small town of adfa that's
not his primary goal his primary goal is
to control Ukraine um his original goal
of course was maximalist to install a
puppet regime in in Kiev um but at a
minimum he wants to make sure that
Ukraine is torn away from the West W
Alliance beat NATO beat EU and general
affiliation with the West territorial
the irony is that the territorial
Conquest does not accomplish that
objective that the more he takes the
donbas does not make uh Kev want want to
be part of Russia or be part of Russia's
um orbit and on the Ukrainian side even
though they obviously want to get back
their territory and even more
importantly get back their people that
is also not the primary objective the
primary objective when I talk to people
in k
is to make sure that this country um is
secure and safe for Generations that
Russia will not do again to it what it
has done um since 2014 which is invade
uh terrorize its people occupy its lands
and I think they would actually take a
deal that gives up at least some of the
territory if not officially then sort of
acquiescing to it if they could ensure
that they could get those security
guarantees be it primarily their
interests in NATO of course Russia would
never allow that deal to happen because
again their focus is not primarily
territory it's to prevent Ukraine from
having that Safety and Security of NATO
because Russia wants to dominate it so I
don't just don't see what kind of deal
is possible and the the challenge that
I've always had with this counter
offensive is even if it had been wildly
successful if you can sort of Imagine a
scenario where Ukraine takes back every
inch of its territory including crimeia
including the danas that would not have
resulted in the War ending all that
would have done is move the front line
to the Ukraine's internationally
recognized borders in fact the Russians
would not have only not Not only would
not have said well that's it we're
giving up we're going back um uh into
Russian territory and giving up on
terrorizing Ukraine they probably would
have mobilized it probably would have um
uh taken even uh worse actions to to
destroy Ukrainian infrastructure and
make life much harder for the Ukrainian
people so at the end of a day I think we
are unfortunately settled in um as we
had really since April of last year in
into this long War of Attrition in some
ways you can think about this war as
having gone on for 10 years almost since
2014 uh in various sitations and I think
unfortunately it could go on for many
years to come not necessarily at the
same level of intensity of combat um but
I just don't see the prospects of
negotiations anytime soon particularly
with Vladimir Putin thinking that he's
got an upper hand I mean Owen in your
piece you mentioned that there was a
point when peace talks were ongoing and
it seemed like that deal could be
reached back in back in March uh 2022 I
mean can you tell us a bit about that
yeah well first I must I must say that
I'm I'm completely shocked that I find
myself in strong agreement with you
Demetri pretty much everything you say
Yes um uh well with the talks um in a
nutshell there's a kind of dangerous and
easy narrative that was uh that is
current in um some Western political
circles um not really in Ukraine but
definitely that's part of the western uh
the you know particularly Ukraine
skeptic uh narrative in the west that um
we made rash promises particularly Boris
Johnson when he arrived in Kiev on 9th
of April 2022 um
of basically unlimited support for
Ukraine and that was the proximate cause
for those series of negotiations that
happened in Minsk then antalia then
Istanbul to collapse um but in fact I I
think um having spoken to a lot of the
principles um it was pretty clear that
by the end of April Sorry by by the
beginning of April um there was not
really any sign that the Russians were
willing to make a deal that would have
been acceptable to Ukraine in any way
shape or form so I the easy thing would
would be to say the ukrainians could
have accepted the loss of land and
neutrality and that would have been the
end of the war but actually the Russians
wanted much more than that they wanted
um uh essentially the Ukraine to sort of
formerly concede uh control over uh the
Russian occupation of of of the donbass
and uh most importantly to agree to
restrictions on their military and um by
that point electorally within Ukraine um
already the horrific images from bua
andin and all the massacres so already
you know by the time the last last time
when Vladimir zinski talked about
negotiations that was actually on April
9th 2022 just a few hours before Johnson
came that was the last time he mentioned
it and that was actually after Bucher
already but already it was pretty clear
there was a sort of land slide of horror
and revulsion from the Ukrainian public
opinion and so uh but on the other hand
that you know the bigger picture is that
the deal that's on the table now is not
a Million Miles Away from the deal that
was on the table in April 22 except
there are two really fundamental
differences and that is that I think
that it's going to be extremely
difficult for the ukrainians to accept
neutrality and they're very in adamant
about full NATO membership and secondly
uh they're not going to accept any
restrictions on their you know on the
military um as for the status of dbass
and crier as Demitri rightly said I
think actually that's not really the the
The crucial part it's um it's really
really about Ukraine's alignment and
that begs a really crucial question to
which I don't really have an answer and
that is is Ukraine joining NATO going to
make Ukraine more secure or less secure
and you know what is so terrible about
Ukraine being a formerly neutral country
like as Finland was from 1940 until it's
joined NATO uh and Sweden was and by the
way also Austria is and uh Switzerland
and Ireland I mean there's lots of
European countries that are forly
neutral but nonetheless have strong
security guarantees from
NATO so uh I think the question going
forward is kind of an existential one uh
for NATO as much as for Ukraine does the
Ukrainian logic that only full
membership of NATO guarantee their
security does that theory hold water or
is actually a some kind of association
with the West with EU membership but not
actual full membership of NATO but with
strong security guarantees from NATO
Partners is that going to be feasible
and and is that going to be politically
acceptable for Ukraine that's a really
interesting question I mean Demitri what
do you think I mean the plenty of people
could say to Ukraine you know you're
never going to be a member of NATO not
while you have disputed borders with
Russia um why not promise Russia that
you won't join up because it's not going
to happen anyway I mean what do you do
you subscribe to that view well again
the key thing for Ukraine is how do they
get um Safety and Security and
assurances that Russia will not invade
again I think they would take something
less than NATO memberships membership if
they could get those security guarantees
from NATO um but the challenge of course
is that the reason that they um are not
able to join NATO is precisely because
no one is willing to extend them those
security guarantees primarily Article 5
um yes there are issues with Ukrainian
modernization and being able to
integrate with NATO but the primary
reason why their objections to them
joining today from both Washington and
the other side of the Atlantic in Europe
is because uh of the belief um that I
think is correct of the dangers of
extending Article 5 um sort of all for
one and one for all security guarantees
to Ukraine that could potentially bring
NATO into conflict with Russia so even
if you do not let Ukraine join NATO but
extend some similar sort of protection
real security guarantees not what was
offered to them in 1994 which of course
was not security guarantees at all but
basically a promise that um their
territorial Integrity would not be
violated which Russia of course did um
and um an obligation by others to Simply
bring this up in the security Council um
um if such a violation occurs um um but
real security guarantees then you know
it's basically the equiv NATO and you
have the fundamental problem again that
it would bring um whoever offers those
security guarantees whether it's us
alone or some combination of um European
countries and the us into a potential
conflict with Russia which they want to
avoid at all costs so that remains the
fundamental issue and by the way from
Russia's perspective it's not really
about NATO it's again because Putin's
goal is to dominate Ukraine and
ultimately tear Ukraine away from its um
Western affiliation um he doesn't want
to see any security guarantees be it
NATO or otherwise that would allow NATO
to be I mean Ukraine to be free uh from
uh fear of conquest by Russia and
controled by Russia so you have the
diametrically oppose maximalist
objectives on both sides I mean Ukraine
is obviously very reasonable and wanting
to protect its country from further
invasions and the Russians wanted to
have the option to execute further
invasions um so that's why I don't see
um a deal here um that would be
palatable to either Moscow or Kev thank
you Dimitri thank you
Owen the Royal racist saga continues P
Morgan named the so-called Royal racist
on his talk TV show last week and the
Pala said to be mulling their resp
response to give us her take I'm joined
by Angela Levin Angela thank you for
joining us on spectator TV pleasure um
yesterday William and Kate and the king
and queen were pictured next to each
other it seemed to be very much a sort
of show of unity um what do you think
the the mood in the palace is like this
past week after the sort of the
revelations from endgame and the sort of
the uh racist Royals R that's been sort
of bubbling along I think each of them
would have a different feeling about it
all but what they have done is learned
this is what Harry does now he doesn't
just attack them once he just goes on
and on and on you know with Netflix with
um Opera winley the first and then that
and then moaning to everybody who he
comes to and um I feel very strongly
that he would have known what um would
be in this book and um he's done
absolutely nothing about it I thought he
would say you you know he's very keen on
suing people he said this is an you know
invasion of my privacy and I won't have
it or say I had nothing to do with this
I'm so sorry everyone but he hasn't done
that and I think that the royal family
have to get thicker skin and actually
just get on with things and they've got
a lot to do and I think it's well it has
brought them together because they know
the pain that each one is feeling um and
they just feel that it's their job is to
be uh part of the raw family and get on
with what they're supposed to do but
Underneath It All it's very painful I
can imagine um since Pi Morgan revealed
the identities of the so-called Royal
racists last week the palace hasn't yet
commented do you think that's a
deliberate strategy of just sort of
trying to Snuff the r the the row out
well they don't move quick quickly they
think before they leap but I believe
that um it's very important to analyze
how that got released because the king
would never have told anybody um that it
was you know talked about it and so you
know there's only one other person who
knows about it because the letters that
Megan wrote um how did that get out and
I think they would do that absolutely
first before they made any movement
there is um rumors that they will you
know sue them but I don't think I don't
think they will because the one thing
they don't want to do and one thing that
Harry really does want them to do is to
have a big Argy bargy row and if there's
anything that goes to court Harry will
be delighted because a he's used to it
and B he can then bring up all the
things that have happened to him in his
life that he resents tiny or not so tiny
and I think he wants to give them a real
um smack with ver a verbal smack and I
don't think they want that they want to
get on with things they don't want to
get muddled up with all that that he
wants you mentioned as well the sort of
we need to get to the bottom of how this
came out I mean there's been an ongoing
sort of controversy this week about how
the names of these of these two Royals
were put in the public domain in omed
sco's book in a Dutch translation I mean
you've released books on the rols before
I mean can how do you how do you think
this kind of thing Could Happen well
it's it's very difficult you have to be
very careful um with the publisher uh I
mean both Queen Camilo I wrot about came
out as biography last year and Prince
Harry came out in 2018 I let them know I
was doing it because I wanted to go on
their engagements and things like that
but um it's the publisher that actually
has to be very careful and always they
send it to the lawyer and they look and
say no you can't say this or change the
word it's too powerful um but it seems
that um sco's um people who the
Publishers did send the wrong one
onto Holland and um I don't know how
that was done I mean you've got to be
very careful and there's lots of
sections in it that are really hideous
as well as the names being mentioned
it's not just one line particularly is
unpleasant about
William which makes you think again I
mean you mentioned this before why
hasn't Harry come out stronger against
this book If he if he doesn't believe
those things I mean yes absolutely I
thought he might the fact that he hasn't
mean he's quite happy with it and I
think that is absolutely appalling and
of course Megan is also very keen on
suing anyone who breaks into her privacy
see and she's done nothing in fact she
was walking down the road the other day
um wearing a bracelet from the king um
that was worth several thousand pounds
smiling away as if you know I've won
this
battle that's how I interpret it some
people say that it's sort of saying oh
I'm sorry but I don't if you say you're
sorry you you say something verbally you
don't just go moving your arm where
you've got your bracelet on
I I can't understand how cruel they've
been actually because certainly for
Megan because she'd have been nobody the
whole thing she's now very well known
she's now very rich because of what has
happened if she didn't like it she could
leave you don't have to try and break
the whole monarchy
down it seems a shame as well and that
before endgame publication it seemed
perhaps that Harry and his father were
approaching something a bit of a ront
you know Harry called his father on his
75th birthday they've been talks about
Christmas them seeing each other I
presume you think that none of that's on
the on the cards now well I didn't
believe it in the first place I thought
why would he suddenly be all cozy and
nice and want to come and why would
Earth would Megan speak to King Charles
if she hates the monarchy so much I
think it was either a ploy set up so
they can be nice and then whack them uh
a week or so later you know there are
people who do that bring someone flowers
and then smash them up um and vindictive
in the extreme I can't see why they did
that they must have known when the book
was coming out um so I thought it was a
very cruel
move um we should mention as well
Harry's been in the papers for another
reason this week which is that he's got
an ongoing case against the home office
about his police protection and can you
tell us a bit about that and what's
going on there yes well Harry feels that
he should have grade one
protection um that means that it would
be policeman and that means they have
guns and they also know all the sort of
intelligence that's going around in that
but it's very expensive and it comes out
of our attx he has that whenever he goes
to something that's Royal you know if he
comes over for a royal event that's uh
he's protected in that way if he's not
doing anything that involves the Royals
he doesn't get that level of protection
because he's now no longer a working
Royal he offered to pay for the police
but they don't want to do that because
um any head of state any head of
companies will feel they deserved it too
so we wouldn't get the police on the
street because they' be looking after uh
other people people but they they've got
very good levels of other protection
officers who can do that for them
without having the gun and without
knowing absolutely the upto-date but
they're very experienced and they're
very good Harry doesn't think that's
good enough for him so this is why he's
taking them back again um but he also
wants it for all four of them so if you
think four sets of top grade police you
need three of them a day you work that
out it's very expensive and he's not
giving anything well he's taking trying
to take away a lot he's not giving
anything towards the royal family so
he's been told not but he feels that
he's been um as usual he's the victim he
hasn't been treated so well we heard
this that he was upset that he got four
sausages and William got five when he
was a little boy so this same thing has
gone on and on and on and on he feels
that it's not fair he hasn't been
treated and it says in the his um lawyer
on his behalf has said that it shouldn't
matter where he
is so this means and I thought this was
the plan all along that he wants us the
UK to pay for wherever he is whatever
he's doing around the world and that's
really cheeky that would have an as
astronomical cost presumably for
taxpayers exactly so this is what that's
all about I think I mean so Harry's made
the argument that he's being treated
potentially unfavorably compared to
other individuals who might be targeted
in a similar way in the UK I mean do you
buy that at all I think he seems to be
implying that it's a sort of Revenge
from the British State almost for his
behavior do do you buy that at all it's
not one of the things he doesn't like is
that they um asked for advice from the
roers about how much he is with the
Royals um so that they knew how much he
was working with them well it's
negligible you see and he can't be up
there I think there'll be a huge rout
from us who pay cash pay tax on on if he
gets that and can go drifting around the
world attacking the monarchy at any
price at any time and that he's given
that sort of protection I understand he
needs protection but he has to go down a
grade or two because of his position now
I think he still fears that he should be
treated the same
way he was as a prince um without doing
anything about it it's having your cake
and eat it isn't it really yeah I mean I
was wondering what you think where where
do you think the sers go from here in
the sense that Harry's had spare now
they've had that Netflix show the public
possibly seem to be getting tired of all
this I mean omad sco's book doesn't seem
to have sold very well this week do you
think they're going to have to take
stock at some point and think what are
we
goinging we're waiting for Megan's
memoirs so there'll be a lather Lo of
nastiness in that one I think that they
they can't make it work out I think
people don't want to hear endless moans
from people living in a house with 16
bathrooms and earning Millions you know
it's sort of it it doesn't work and
what's happened is nothing has happened
there's lots of things that they say
they're going to do but they doesn't
work out Megan was going to be starring
in a film but she demanded a top grade
editor no one wants to be there you know
they're difficult to work with and so um
when she was at she was at a some a Ward
and then people said to her what do you
want to do now and she said oh I want to
do something it's really exciting I want
to make people
feel now I don't know what that
means okay um and that means to me
actually it's not much going on and a
lot of people are avoiding them now and
instead of actually being positive and
maybe having a grown gr sort of
annoying period and then coming back in
and and getting together and being
positive but they're not they're moaning
all the time and do you think they were
banking as well a bit on the Americans
sort of appreciating their celebrity and
their connections with the Royals and
now perhaps the Americans are kind of
tiring them tiring of them as well well
the Americans have got very tired of
them they don't like moners either and
also they don't trust them because they
can tell that whatever they do and say
they sell it off not everything but a
lot of the things they pass on and make
some money out of it and a lot of the
a-listers um now don't want anything to
to do with them anymore um and also of
course the Duke of Westminster has not
invited them to their w to his wedding
in the summer and that's a very
interesting thing and he was he was um
Arch's Godfather is Arch's Godfather
he's William's Godfather for uh little
George um and he is the king is his
Godfather and um so he's very high up
and I think um he didn't want a a mess
or upset the raw family that's it if
people are going to choose between Harry
and Megan and William and Katherine and
the king and queen it's quite obvious
where they're going to go brilliant
thank you very much
Angela and finally Sam Leaf The
Spectators literary editor joins the
show to give us his books of the Year
Sam thank you for joining us on
spectator TV uh we're getting close to
the end of the year now um and you're
going to talk to us about your favorite
books of 2023 so um to start us off what
what what what actually were they
well um there have been a few and but I
should start with a disclaimer because I
think some people I'm often surprised by
the number of people who think that a
literary editor's job is to read all the
new books that come out each year and
actually my job is to subcontract that
so the new books I've read are often
quite a kind of random selection rather
than a kind of absolute panoptic
overview of what's come out this year
but um recently as I think I said in our
books of the Year feature in the SP
I was knocked out by Nicholas
Shakespeare's book on in Fleming um
which is just a stupendous work of
research I mean he's you know everybody
has ever written a now forgotten novel
that has a minor character in it he's
faintly based on some incident involving
Fleming you know he's read and tracked
it down and he basically discovers that
in Fleming's kind of more important than
the man wrote James Bond um and that
yeah well and just sort of really it's
an amazing scoop filled book about the
secret intelligence work that went on in
the second world war um at the center of
which it turns out Fleming was yeah
because I'd never really um realized
this before I mean I'm not a massive
Fleming or Bond fan but the sort of he
was involved in sort of quite mad
intelligence Capers himself wasn't he
Fleming is that right well he was I mean
he wasn't doing as much James Bond agent
in the field stuff as you might have
thought though there was a little bit of
that I mean he was sent off to kind of
ret R the Belgian gold reserves and
smuggle them to safety from the Nazis at
one point um but he was I mean basically
the reason he didn't do much in the
field is because he knew too much and it
would be too dangerous to get him
captured he was really unlike other sort
of spy and intelligence adjacent writers
like lare or gram green who kind of gave
out that they were kind of quite
important in the Secret Service and
really weren't Fleming was the real deal
I mean he he's so sort of chaired very
early incarnations of the joint
intelligence committee he was privy to
the sort of top secret documents that
only a very small like a dozen or half a
dozen people would be able to lay eyes
on and he trained up this Commando group
who went raiding Europe after dday you
know basically trying to find Cutting
Edge German technological secrets so he
was he was really the real deal and that
that's a kind of extraordinary thing
that Nicholas is
you know
negotiated um all the silences and the
record because a lot of the stuff still
hasn't been Declassified and found you
know even found some old boy who'd
actually been in member of that Commando
unit and had met Fleming so he do all
sorts of extraordinary stuff it's a it's
absolutely gripping book and Nicholas
Shakespeare being a really really good
writer it's it's beautifully written as
well as profoundly researched brilliant
that sounds like a fantastic
recommendation another book that struck
me very strongly um was shortlisted for
the Samuel Johnson as was and bayy gford
prize as now is our major non-fiction
prize um didn't win in the end um was
Tanya branagan's red memory I
interviewed her for our podcast um I
think in the summer and she's a China
correspondent who spent you know several
years in China reporting on China and
it's it's the fruit of her realization
while she was there that the cultural
revolution is something that never
talked about in China but that is just
millimeters below the surface you know
it completely informs the way China is
but it's a kind of repressed memory um
and it's about I it's not only about
what happened in the culture of
Revolution but really about the way in
which it has been forgotten or
suppressed or romanticized in some cases
or you know co-opted in others and it's
really about
China's negotiation with its own past
and also about the fact there's a
country that I mean she says of China
more or less what um the great Mas
gueston has said of Russia that it's a
essentially a country suffering
Collective
PTSD um so it's absolutely gripping book
it's extraordinarily well reported and
well written and it just tells you a lot
about what you know quite how how
traumatic those events were and how
close they remain to you know just under
the surface of China's Consciousness
yeah I think that's something i' not
appreciated enough actually is that how
close it was it of there'll be lots of
people that it's living memory for
example it's not just absolutely
absolutely that and and some of them
weirdly because as you probably know the
cultural revolution basically involved a
complete inversion of all the
traditional Confucian setup in China
where old older people respected and
tradition was respected basically got a
bunch of teenage Hooligans and
encouraged them to go around smashing
everything up and denouncing their
olders and their teachers and you know
their parents even with fatal
consequences I mean literally fatal
consequences and and yet a lot of the
veterans of this you know those those
teenagers who've now grown up um some of
them remember it kind of fondly because
a you know it was exciting and B they it
was kind of like this weird you know
think of those American Spring Break
movies only with Mur you know they were
all sent off to to roam around the
countryside on on exciting
train you know special trains were laid
on and they go all over the place you
know basically having riots um but you
know they looked back on it with some
fondness it was they got to travel they
got to see places they hadn't seen and
they got to you know have teachers put
to death so you know very very very
weird you mentioned another spy novel as
well I believe one of the M oh well
there's another spy novel so I my spy
novels um well not I mean Bond as a spy
novel were spy novels but the that book
was book about the biography of the
creator of bond um but I I by now it's
become almost kind of boiler plate for
everybody who likes fins to greet a new
mck Heron with oh it's a new M Heron
it's wonderful but you know mck Heron
really is bliss and the new one is
called um the secret hours I mean you
probably know mck Heron's stuff he's
he's WR written a series which now on
Apple TV with Gary Oldman you know he's
he's gone from being a sort of Niche
taste that those in the know appreciate
to like super famous ER lar sort of
stuff but he writes comic spy novels
about basically crap spies um who have
been kind of cashiered into the sort of
Dunces Department of
MI5 but they always end up doing some
actual spying and it's always very
exciting and perilous um and they're
sort of
funny I mean really funny um but also
you know do the proper work of Thrillers
anyway um the new one the secret hours
is is a it's a sort of prequel um
because the slow House series um which
he does is sort of contemporary and this
is one set in the bowels of the Cold War
um and involving Jackson lamb his kind
of fantastically carismatic and
unpleasant spy Master as a young man um
so it's in Berlin and it's all the all
the satisfactions of slow horses but you
know transposed to the the 60s I early
60s or late 50s do you um Sam do you
think that the lare comparisons are fair
and if any viewers are big fans of lare
do you think they would would enjoy
Heron's works I think so I mean the car
is kind of a sober sides Heron is a
comic novelist um as much as he's a spy
writer
and it's I mean I it certainly kind of
takes some cues from lar not least
because slow house his um his sort of
home for home for spies who are in
disgrace is essentially you know it's a
kind of um funh house mirror version of
lcar circus um but the satisfactions of
lare in terms of plotting and action and
Intrigue are all there the writing is
beautiful and and it's got jokes um so I
I think it's got everything a lar fan
could hope for and a bit more he's also
it should be said he's not a
lary imitator or copyist I mean he's
he's influenced by lend Dayton out of
thought is L car but again lendon and L
Car neither of them jokes in quite the
same way so he's no he's the full
package he's a great thing L car oh very
good and uh tell us about your last book
only to make myself sound clever is um
Carlo rll's anaximander and the nature
of science which book came out right at
the beginning of the year and I was
lucky enough to have car rellan to talk
about it relli as probably our viewers
will know is
a um I mean he a theoretical physicist
of quite some distinction he works on
something called luk quantum gravity um
which I still haven't the faintest idea
what that is but he's also he's sort of
at the top of the range of that great
generation of you know hinky quantum
physics explainers um to those of us who
cannot do the extremely hard sums that
it involves um and so he's I mean he
kind of made his name with this thing
called seven brief Le lessons in physics
which was a kind of collection of short
lectures which would just explain to you
you know some aspect of the absolutely
wibbly wobbly world of of quantum theory
anaximander the new book um or actually
it's the last but one book now because
he's just done one one of white holes um
and a Mand was thrilling to me because
it's relli writing about somebody's one
of his Heroes I mean rll is kind of very
cultivated person you know he's got a
sort of hint land he's not just a you
know straight down the line physicist um
but he's someone who you know he's
interested in poetry and literature and
culture and politics and how science
fits into that um and what an ax amander
is about is rll's hero who is this guy
who lived you know before the age even
of
Aristotle and was arguably the world's
first scientist and he was the first
person
to um and his great Great Notion was
that the Earth rather than being
something that is completely flat and
sit underneath the sky he said he
deduced that the Earth was a body
floating in space and that the Sun and
the Moon as they go kind of pass under
it around it rather than sort of
Vanishing at the end of the end of the
day and kind of reappearing magically at
the other end um and he made all sorts
of other um insights including the idea
that you know essentially he said there
were naturalistic explanations to things
so he made extraordinary guess at how
the water cycle works you know this
hundreds of years before the birth of
Christ um and he started to think about
how materials affected each other I mean
he it's basically he started trying to
find scientific or material causes for
things rather than mystical ones and his
method was a scientific method was the
idea of you know this paparian idea of
FAL if and what relli does is is talks a
little about anaximander what we know of
him which is not all that much um and
how he related to his predecessors and
teachers and how his work comes down to
us and you know what he knew and what he
didn't know but it's not so much what
atanda discovered that rll is excited by
it it's the way he was thinking and the
way he was thinking was essentially
completely new um and re then with great
grace and elegance as you'd expect from
from a writer of his caliber sort of
talks about how those discoveries and
that way of thinking resonates through
subsequent history and how the
scientific method you know why the
scientific method matters and the
effects it's had on the world we live in
and it's just it's an extraordinarily
intellectually thrilling book I have to
say does he feel that animex Ander has
the kind of same kind of scientific
method today or does he feel like it's
been distorted or does feel like it was
a very sort of primitive version of that
do you think well I think in the very
broadest sense he does I mean what he
sort of says is like it doesn't matter
that an ax Amanda thought you know the
Earth was a cylinder um or that he you
know got this and that wrong he said
it's not you know it's it it's the way
of thinking and the way of thinking was
one in which you sought natural causes
for things rather
than you know looking to gods or magic
to explain the phenomena of the world
around you um and that
anaximander took what his predecessor I
think was thees and myus I can't
remember off on my head he said he took
what the's thought and he learned from
it and he then kind of modified it
slightly he said you know this is all
good but he got this bit wrong and how
about if he thought and he said you know
that's what that's what science does you
know it's incremental it's Collective it
involves falsifying or modifying
previous results while same time
learning from him so in the very
broadest sense I think he claims an aand
as a modern BR thank you very much
Sam that's it for this week once again
if you enjoy spectator TV do subscribe
to our YouTube channel just click the
Subscribe button at the bottom of this
video and tap the Bell icon so you never
miss an episode thanks again for
watching and do join us again next
[Music]
week